just as a quick comment because this is
fascinating
in august of last year there was this
uh medalla i believe it's pronounced
madasha it's a
south american subway station i forget
where but spell with two elves
yeah yeah because that's you know that's
how spanish works right like the two
elves have uh
with dasha okay cool anyway but i read
about it
in uh middle of august august 14th there
was an incident
on that test net what how does this
process work like what do you learn from
those kinds of incidents when stuff goes
wrong
in the test process i think
that incident was that there was a
consensus failure of some kindness i
remember
um basically just different clients
interpreting things in different ways
and then one of them getting kicked off
the network
and then it ended up taking a while to
actually like
get everyone to get back online like a
big part of the reason why it took weeks
to resolve right is because uh
it's on a test network like the coins
are valueless and so there's
not really this big push of any kind for
people to actually
you know going down with a new client so
they can start participating again
and so you know it definitely took a
while until the chain started finalizing
again um
but and then also like there was i think
another
round of just not finalizing in october
as i remember
um that i mean there were definitely
things that we learned like there were a
lot of things especially that
client developers just learned about
like optimization
and how to build their clients in a way
that they can process things
efficiently um there's a a lot that we
learned from just like seeing the full
life cycle of what happens when
more than a third of the validators go
offline and then finalization stops
and then that kind of
weird unusual state of the chain
continues for a while and then
eventually everyone who is not
participating but just
gets enough of their stake like we don't
use the word swash we use the word weak
for this but like basically also burned
um until you know the people who are
participating go back up to two thirds
and then the chain
goes back to finalizing so just seeing
all of those edge cases play out live i
think actually helped a lot and probably
helped to really contribute to
making us feel better about midnet i
mean there's also an incident
just recently in april 24th
of 2021 where uh
this was on beacon i guess uh there was
a bug discovered in the software client
prism
that prevented roughly 70 of validators
on the network from producing blocks
i mean maybe you can comment on what
happened but
broadly like the big picture what kind
of stuff are you worried about
in terms of problems that might arise
we're talking about small bugs
i were talking about like emergent
social unexpected social bugs
you know what are the things that worry
about the future of ethereum that
you want to make sure you construct
mechanisms that prevent those things
from happening
so one of the lucky things there was
that this particular bug only prevented
proposals of blocks it did not prevent
attestations
right so at the stations is just a
mechanism for voting on blocks
and it's the attestations that are
actually responsible for the chain
finalizing so like coming to this
more permanent agreement on blocks right
so the chain was actually quite stable
all the way through
um the i think the thing that we
generally
learn from these experim experiences
is just how valuable it is to have this
some multi-client network
right so this is one of these areas
where i think it's ethereum
distinguishes itself from like bitcoin
for example
right that in ethereum we don't have
one single client that that everyone
um just runs right there's multiple
implementations of
the protocol and these multiple
implementations they're they all
process and verify the blocks that each
other can
you know verify right so they all speak
the same language
now sometimes when there's a bug they
disagree right and
when two clients disagree because of a
bug we call this a consensus failure
and consensus failures are pretty
serious right and when
you have um a client's monoculture like
bitcoin does
then like it's more rare to have
consensus failures though you still have
them actually bitcoin had a consensus
failure between two different versions
of the same client back in 2013.
um but they're less likely to happen but
the interesting thing is that the
multi-client architecture has actually
i think saved ethereum much more than
it's heard it
so even in this most recent incidents
right like prism was not producing
blocks but all the other clients were
still producing blocks
um there's four others right yes it's a
prism
nimbus teku and the white house okay um
and then also ethereum back in 2016 had
this fun
event that we call the shanghai dos
attacks uh they're called that because
uh
the attacks started like right on the
first day of
our annual conference at defcon that
happens to be in shanghai that year
so what happened like basically was that
someone came up with a way to create
blocks
that were very slow for one clients to
process but not the other client
so at that time there were basically two
ethereum clients there were they were
called geth and parody
um right now i think the top three ones
are
geth nethermind and beso um but
what happened as a result of us having
two clients is that the attacker was
just
not able to come up with blocks that
both clients were
like uh completely failing at processing
and so like a lot of the miners and a
lot of network participants they just
kept on switching between the two
implementations
depending on which one worked and that
actually really helped the
change the the chain i kind of survived
through that month of attacks as the
attacker just like kept on
hammering at our system and identifying
all of the weaknesses
and just like forcing our clients to do
this you know
rapid sprint of just like optimizing the
hell out of everything and make sure
there aren't any of those uh dos blocks
or uh
and dos bugs remaining um so that was
another example
and then like as a counterpoint as a
counter example so
like something that also shows the point
from the other side
um bitcoin had this bug in 2010 right
the
balance overflow bug basically someone
created a transaction that had two
outputs and those
outputs had were both of a few billion
bitcoin
so like about two to the power of 63
satoshis
and then if you add those numbers
together you go above to the power of
64.
and of course you know computers like
once you go above to the power of 64 you
wrap around
and so the bitcoin nodes thought that
there was enough money to pay for the
transaction because it was asking for
let's say like a billion satoshis or
something but actually it was asking for
to the power of 64 plus a billion and so
you know the attacker just managed to
create like
billions of bitcoin out of thin air and
this was not only discovered and fixed
after something like 12 hours
um but you know if there had been if
bitcoin had been a multiple
implementation system
then what would have almost certainly
happened
is like one of the clients would have
bugged out but the other clients would
have
probably you know actually had a check
for that right and so
there would have been a consensus
failure but at least that would have
um like alerted everyone that there is a
problem very
quickly and it also would have given
everyone just like obvious social
permission to go and
you know pick which whichever one of the
chains is correct and solve the problem
um so like that's
i think a big learning that we've had
from multiple
of our experiences in the ethereum
ecosystem just like
validating this multi-client model you
know to be fair it's an auto that we get
criticized for a lot right like
bitcoin people talk about you know the
risk of consensus failures that this
creates
um vc types are like well you know isn't
it expensive and wasteful to funds three
software teams where you could just be
making you know one
quote focused effort you know they love
the word focused and like you know
ethereum is not that but it's amazing
despite not being that
yeah um the
basically yes so that was interesting
and and then you know there have
definitely been other
learnings as well just from like seeing
the chain live and
you know seeing what actually is the
staking experience
like what are the actual incentives for
all the different participants
so i definitely feel like we're gaining
a lot from this sort of
one year of uh trial running the chain
before we actually make all of ethereum
depend on it
you